let's bring in Greg Sankey he's the
Commissioner of the SEC he took over
that title in 2015 Fritzie how do you
have an Ohio State Jersey on with the
Commissioner the SEC on in all honestly
I just grabbed it should have realized
that that was a poor decision on my part
but it was not something that was not
taking a shot
of course the bow at the Commission
sorry commissioner sorry about that what
when are the performance evaluations I'd
like to have I'd like to have some input
what sports you want you know none how's
that I'm watching replays of games I
attended I actually watched the CFP
National Championship game a couple
nights ago I've been there and you know
you've been to enough events when you're
at the event you don't watch the event
you're in the same way so it was fun to
actually go see what I thought happened
compared to what actually did happen we
won what kind of toll did March Madness
not being played have on the SEC well
you know there's a financial impact to
put that aside the most emotional moment
for me was having to make a
recommendation to our presidents and our
Chancellor's that we canceled our men's
basketball tournament if you'll recall
back in 2008 we had a basketball
tournament interrupted by a tornado and
we stayed up all night we made it
through Georgia ends up winning and they
had finished in the bottom half of our
standings and one of those moments for
me and nobody knew who I was back then I
was an associate commissioner I'm
walking down the hallway and there's a
Georgia player holding the trophy
walking towards me saying over and over
this is the best day of my life and
that's one of those moments where the
tickets the the TV the attendance kind
of goes by the wayside and you realize
the importance of competition so so not
being able to play hurt in in a very
different way and then the rest of the
month I would call a celebration that's
the enjoyable part of the job to see
teams compete you know last year all
burns render the final floor was was
really enjoyable and you hope for a
national championship South Carolina I
think would have been the number one
women's team so we had an opportunity to
to win which is always part of that fun
we'll get to the NCAA in a moment but
what kind of plan it feels like every
league every Commissioner there's
alternative plans here are there
alternative plans for college football
in the fall there's the conversation you
know are there sure is that the focus no
the focus is on preparing to play as
scheduled
Labor Day weekend I think that's an
important message publicly I think it's
important for our student-athletes to
hear from me that we're focused on that
preparation now whether or not we can
make that happen that's gonna be up to
the circumstances around the virus but
no foot you know football with no fans
not not something I have to decide right
now and I'm high on my priority list for
thinking about now whether whether the
fan patterns look different that's
that's another question that again we've
learned a lot in the last 30 to 45 days
we're gonna learn a lot more in the next
45 days and we've got you know a little
over a hundred days to the start of what
would be football season as scheduled
and that'll guide how we make those
decisions but I wonder if you have
students on campus then do we is there a
correlation between that students on
campus fans in the stands or is that a
big leap there I don't think it's a big
leap Dan I think the first threshold is
our campus is moving back towards
operation and you see really on a daily
basis universities across the country
talking about moving forward with their
fall plan so that's that's the first
step the the patterns and and how people
enter and leave and where they sit are
all those other types of conversations
that yeah is it linked to students being
on campus or is it directly linked I
don't think you can make the statement
that it's all one seamless process
explain to me if you can in layman's
terms about what you think these
athletes are going to be able to
capitalize on with their likeness and
and how do we keep it
above board that's a heck of a question
you just boiled it right down to its
essence but let's just take a step back
for a second remember a year ago
California's in this debate about its
state legislation the NCAA sends the
letter says they better be careful about
Championships participation and a year
later we're talking about
operationalizing student athlete name
image and likeness so there are some
easy elements if you if you read what is
a 31 page report which I haven't had the
time to read Jeff because I first saw it
yesterday one element is businesses like
student athletes operating businesses
within we've had people do that do it
really well we had a football player one
of our universities around a landscaping
businesses whole college career believe
it or not and did quite well you never
knew it we have another student athlete
who played in the NFL wrote a book you
know worked with the compliance office
did it in a great way now can you just
say we're gonna run businesses and all
the sudden the boosters don't you know
take over and make it a recruiting issue
that's the aboveboard piece and that's
where there are a lot of questions still
to be answered in my view but okay can
let's say I am on the car dealership and
I'm in Athens Georgia and I want to say
to the quarterback come on over
Saturdays non football season and you
you can sign autographs once a week and
I'm gonna pay you $100,000 is that legal
well that remains to be seen I'll back
you up and say we have a football
Leadership Council where I have taken
them through that exercise I didn't put
the hundred thousand dollars on it
because I'm not sure that's necessarily
real-world right now could that happen
so I'm gonna put that hypothetical aside
but I just talked through a room of
starters from each of our 14 teams the
process of people reaching out asking
about appearances asking about showing
up at a car dealership at a restaurant
you know high value time would be
football season and our student athletes
have said to us for years I don't have
enough time in my life right now they
are very good about identifying where
they should have
space when you actually walk through the
exercise of scheduling appearances
having contracts
what's the rate going to be where I'm
gonna find the time we literally ended
with a with a question to me of one how
come I the University help me in this
process and that hasn't been answered
for us yet
and then the next observation was I
don't know that I want this and we're
talking about high-level competitors
saying you know what I'm preparing for
football would we have sixty three guys
drafted last week and I think you've got
this tension between the the focused
competitor and the distractions and
we're gonna have to find that balance
quite frankly he's the Commissioner of
the SEC Greg Sankey joining us Dan
Patrick show Johnny Manziel under the
new guidelines would have been allowed
to do what Johnny Manziel was doing at
Texas A&M right signing autographs
oh well that's been identified as one of
those activities yeah we've had a few of
those eruptions overtime but we'll go
with that one yeah that's why I'm trying
to understand here because I don't know
does this how does this benefit college
football if you're gonna allow these
student athletes to capitalize on their
likeness are we are we getting away from
hey you got to pay them I you know that
maybe that question doesn't get asked
anymore of Mark Emmert in the NCAA so
I'm trying to figure out what's the
benefit for college football well I
think the question does is asked its
asked of mark its asked of the NCAA
globally it's it's asked of me and we're
not in a pay for play mode and we've
said that as a principle so this isn't
an idea and let's go back to the
California law the California state law
very clearly said here's the
circumstances around this name image and
likeness activity those concepts by the
way have been out there in different
areas whether it's in media conversation
and discussions and lawsuits so now what
does it mean it means that an individual
gets to go act in their own interest and
decide do i or do I not want to be
involved in economic activity the
responsibility University is provide the
support basis be it the scholarship at
academic support mental health
but the individual student athlete gets
to go function somewhat like a student
who wanted to go sell autographs by the
way I don't see a lot of students out
there successfully selling their
autographs for university campuses of
some of these comparatives I think get a
little bit twisted if you changed his
jersey from Ohio State to LSU
[Laughter]
I'm sure he how to be really get your
master's degree to here's the tough
question if I could only go to one
tailgate in the SEC oh that's like
dangerous for me because I have 14
favorite University just one like I mean
all that is is trouble for I know that I
know that that's why I said that's the
tough questions like have you ever been
to a football game at the University of
Montana and like minus 10 degrees that's
a memorable tale I would love I would
love to do that I grew up in Ohio I'm
not afraid well cold
Ole Miss very clearly has distinguished
them if its caloric intake you're gonna
be in Baton Rouge for creative food
choices when you're me you usually don't
walk through a lot of tailgates because
there are opinions expressed oh and in
their own creative ways food like the
NFL Commission like how do fans treat
you because you're the commissioner they
see yeah pretty well you know there were
when LSU had its celebration you know
when you're in a figure an authority
position you're gonna get a few few boos
so I started out with my remarks there
were just a few people in the arena and
I observed I asked the question what do
you think of the first year of beer
sales in Tiger State there's a
commissioner you got to have those
moments when you can turn the turn the
the criticism into something more
positive
you should also since you're joining us
from I don't know if that your den but
your home I think my home office yeah
the angle that you have with
zoom camera you need to do sort of like
the Batman logo that they would always
do what they would like you should put
an SEC logo above you like a spot like
that has SEC right above your head there
on the ceiling well I'll tell you what I
did for a zoom call a couple weeks ago I
did have a colleague on and I grabbed I
have three mini CFP championship
trophies and I placed them right over my
shoulder here in the background I didn't
I didn't do that for you today I I've
gotta I gots a good memorabilia or my
Huey Lewis autographed sports poster
over here I could have thrown up wait
you got a Huey Lewis autographed poster
yeah okay
why it was the 80s right sports album
yeah well and you know you were a golf
coach weren't you before and he was a
ton of golf that was a long time ago
actually not as long ago as the 80s but
very close to it commissioners great to
talk to you and we appreciate your time
good luck with navigating you got you
got some choppy waters there ahead and I
don't envy you but hopefully we'll be
able to get through this what's clear is
we've answered all the easy questions
and only the hard ones are left that's
true thank you thank you that's the
Commissioner of the SEC I appreciate his
time